benefit 2.0 has reached fairy tale
status and it just turned out to be
something really magical e.t has new
details about jennifer lopez's romance
with you-know-who with ben affleck how's
that amazing a source close to the
couple tells e.t j.lo and ben are doing
great and all has been good with them
both are working a lot but nick plans to
spend time with the family as well as
each other
we give it away but it has a very good
ending
the source adds that ben is making
jennifer quote laugh constantly her kids
also love ben and feel comfortable with
him they feel like it's a fairy tale
right now
well j lo the feeling is very mutual i'm
ready i'm excited about it in an
interview last month ben praised
jennifer's influential career in the
entertainment industry
quote i am in awe of what jennifer's
effect on the world is at most as an
artist i can make movies that move
people jennifer has inspired a massive
group of people to feel they have a seat
at the table in this country that is an
effect few people throughout history
have had one i will never know and one i
can only stand by and admire with
respect
i think we had chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working plus
another source told et the duo will be
celebrating the holidays as a couple
i like those christmas sweaters baby the
source said quote they want to be
together all the time so their next big
things are thanksgiving and christmas
we're trying to get some can you see if
we can get in the papers because i'm
trying to get could i listen ask and you
shall receive mr affleck
that's ben and jlo at the premiere of
the last duel which is just one of their
many pda-packed moments recently
you know it's wild to think about it
that way
ben and jen turned all the heads with
their red carpet comeback at the venice
film festival last month they were seen
laughing having intimate convos and
holding hands which was quickly followed
by yet another night out for the
lovebirds
after jennifer's solo arrival at the met
gala the couple reunited inside and even
shared a masked kiss
[Music]